it's December time to go to the theater
to spend some quality time with your
family quality time away from your
family or just some good old fashioned
me time
hashtag treat yourself what will you see
this is your weekend ticket December
preview
[Music]
once upon a Deadpool a pg-13 re-release
of Deadpool - with 20 minutes of new
footage I loved you're working up don't
get too attached mortal engines a
post-apocalyptic adventure film based on
the novel by the same name with a
screenplay written by Fran Walsh
Philippa boyens and the Lord of the
Rings director Peter Jackson the mule a
crime drama starring produced and
directed by Clint Eastwood about a world
war ii veteran who became a drug dealer
and courier for the Sinaloa cartel need
help sir Oh officer hi spider-man into
the spider-verse
an animated spider-man film starring
Jake Johnson shameik Moore
and involving a parallel dimension
multiple spider-man team-up
I'm from another another dimension how
many more spider people are there hey
fellas
this could literally not get any weirder
it can get weird okay MARY POPPINS
returns the long overdue sequel to the
original now with Emily Blunt is Mary
Poppins and lin-manuel Miranda as Jack
Aquaman the DC superhero brought to life
by Jason Momoa rare bumblebee the
spin-off movie of the Transformers
franchise starring John Cena and Hailee
Steinfeld here's the deal
people can be terrible about things they
don't understand from now on only person
you can show yourself around his me good
second act
starring JLo and meelo Ventimiglia
second act follows a frustrated 40 year
old in her pursuit to reinvent her
career I gave you a completely new
identity you said you wanted to be fancy
so I just like Cinderella Jurassic well
I got you in the door you got the job
baby who's the champ let's go
who's the champ on the tail you're the
you're the champ welcome to Marwin steve
carell stars in this Robert Zemeckis
directed drama about an assault victim
who constructs a miniature world war two
village in his yard to help him cope and
recover Holmes and Watson a comedic take
on the classic Sherlock Holmes
characters with Will Ferrell and john c
reilly who was going to take the
photograph I will take it you see it's
sort of a self photograph he's a real
fan I swear I never do this hey girl and
finally Vice a biographical drama d
about Dick Cheney's plot to become the
most powerful VP ever yeah right so
bundle up because December's gonna be a
good one
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see check back next week for an
in-depth look at Clint Eastwood's
furrowed brow
[Music]
[Music]